[Music]
you probably are reading uh the new
autobiography by arnold schwarzenegger
i'm sure you're reading it
i see some of you reading it now uh
it's everyone's talking about it he
makes some stunning claims in this book
one of them i couldn't believe arnold
revealed
that he fought james cameron over using
the line i'll be back
bought him didn't want to say it that
line has since been voted one of the
greatest movie catchphrases of all time
and i guess arnold said i don't think
it's gonna work yeah so apparently
before he finally gave in and did the
line uh arnold tried to do the line his
own way a couple of times we looked into
it we found the takes
i go away but here's the thing i then
return
let's revisit this discussion later on
ttfn tata for now catch you on the flip
side and by that i mean i'll be
departing and then returning at the time
the mutually convenient
amigo bye-bye
[Applause]
[Music]
wouldn't you have been happier with me
go bye-bye
yes
me go bye-bye